well this is super cool I can't believe
you're here at Toronto pride yeah it's
gonna be such a fun day I'm hot but fun
day it's gonna be a part the fun day and
this is not your first pride what do you
love about playing Pride festivals it's
just the most joyful experience so I
think I've ever had ever if you haven't
come to a pride thing you really have
them experience what it is to truly
celebrate it is just such a good
celebration and we're gonna be
celebrating you're gonna be on the Bud
Light float singing feels right the
remix with Jordan Alexander totally
about recording that in LA with Jordan
cuz that's super cool you know I hadn't
met her until she had come down to Los
Angeles but we had heard her voice and
some of her songs and we're really
excited to picture him and she just
ended up being a little angel like sweet
excited enthusiastic and really talented
so I felt really lucky to have her on
the song and she added her own verse
that she wrote herself so it's gonna be
a fun day for her to showcase that
that's so cool it already has I believe
off 1.5 million streams which is
incredible and I mean Bud Light is just
doing so many great things teaming up
with rainbow railroad which helps people
escape violence within the LGBTQ
community so this is awesome they really
are they're all about just kind of
sharing the lab and spreading the love
and I think that's why we were so
excited to say yes what what would you
say pride means to you personally I
think it's it's more than the acceptance
with celebration it's celebration of
everyone's uniqueness and allowing there
to be space for at all and I think
that's a message that I have been
carrying with me from the get-go and
will continue to yes I did a story on
you on et Canada pride maybe a month ago
when dedicated came out and as I was
going through I saw so many instances
since the beginning of your career
whether that be quotes or interviews of
you supporting the lgbtq+ community so
thank you for that story and I'm like oh
my gosh since day one you have been a
strong ally and that means a lot to so
many people so thank you thank you and
well I'm a little nervous I don't get
nervous doing interviews usually but I'm
a huge fan
how does it feel to have the new album
out because I'm sure you know there was
a little bit of nerves going into it and
it's been so well received I was nervous
I was almost paralyzed with the fear of
it but um it feels really great to have
it out and to see the response so far
and we're getting ready to go on tour
after this so this is my glass like kind
of festival II gig and then we start the
dedicated tourists outcomes yes if
you're free we're gonna have fun try and
make it as fun as cried oh it's gonna be
fun I came to see you when you performed
at the TSO a little while ago I was I
was front row for that and I have
tickets to the dedicated tour so what
can fans of carly rae jepsen expect from
the dedicated to our well you know it's
funny because the first tour I did
outside of Canada was opening for Justin
so it was just me was huge overwhelming
and I almost didn't know where to put my
hands and I feel like we've really
worked since that time to almost like
take the staircase of building up a tour
that feels authentic to me as the pop
artist I've become and this is it this
is the tour I've been working my whole
life to make and I finally feel like I'm
really in my in my groove so I hope you
come in wanna dance I'm gonna be dancing
wish me luck
[Music]
finally I would love to know what does
the lgbtq+ community do for you how does
it inspire you when you're making music
do you even think that way about it or
is it just an inspiration everyday life
for you I think in general I there's a
feeling of acceptance that you get back
I feel like I've been taught to embrace
myself in a bigger way and that you know
on stage at the Pride event I remember
feeling like I was about to fall on
those funds and I remember feeling like
the room was so full of love but even if
I did everyone feel like it's alright
like get up together and I think that's
what it's about that's what it's all
about love everybody let's spread the
love today and I'm so excited to see you
on that float later yeah thank you thank
you
you